bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau format de vidéo ou aujourd'hui
on va s'attaquer aux clichés qui servent
à combattre les clichés en biologie
évolutive alors on va faire une petite
mise en situation
regardez ce coelacanthe c'est un
magnifique fossile vivant et donc mais
pas du tout c'est une espèce manque
rooney guillon mais c'est quoi la
différence entre un fossile vivant une
espèce pont chronique ici très simple et
très simple un fossile vivant c'est une
espèce qui n'évolue plus n'a pas évolué
voilà et puis n'est-ce point chronique
et bien c'est une espèce qui n'évolue
plus mais c'est pas pareil et c'est pas
pareil non c'est pas pareil alors pour
tous ceux d'entre vous qui sont d'accord
avec le fait qu'un fossile vivant ça
n'existe pas puisque évidemment pour
qu'une espèce n'évolue absolument pas il
faudrait que les mutations n'est
absolument pas lieu et ça c'est juste
chimiquement impossible ce n'est pas
comme ça que l'adn fonctionne donc un
fossile vivant ça ne peut pas exister
mais alors du coup si une espèce pour
chronique c'est exactement la même chose
oui oui on a un petit problème c'est sur
la définition n'est pas terrible la
définition est pas terrible donc pendant
le coelacanthe justement on dit que
c'est une espèce en chronique mais alors
une espèce pont chronique sachant qu'il
ya trois espèces maintenant de sela
quant au moins deux reconnus mais la
troisième dernières découvertes laquelle
et le fossile vivant laquelle est
l'espèce pour chronique
en tout cas on n'a aucun fossile
d'aucune détroit donc c'est quand même
dur de ligne donc si on a envie de dire
qu'une espèce pont chronique c'est une
espèce dont la morphologie n'a pas
changé au cours du temps comment on fait
pour le coelacanthe parce qu'on a pas de
faux cils on a des analyses adn qui de
toute façon montrent qu'elles ont évolué
et de toute façon il n'ya même pas de
fossiles du genre la team est rien
puisque les trois coelacanthe qui vivent
aujourd'hui sont tous du genre latimer
ya donc le sait laisser là quand c'est
juste des espèces point chronique par
rapport aux autres espèces de ces lacs
ans qui ont vécu par le passé dans ce
cas là c'est toute la famille des
coelacanthe qui est une espèce manque
chronique mais alors là on touche à un
autre problème ça veut dire que si
maintenant on est capable de regarder
n'importe quoi et dire que tant qu'il ya
quelque chose de la même famille qui vit
encore aujourd'hui
vous prenez n'importe qui mais voilà si
vous prenez n'importe quel faux cils
espèce fossile et s'il ya encore un
représentant actuel c'est une espèce
pont chronique voilà taire les oiseaux
les oiseaux et c'est complètement en
cause mais les oiseaux c'est depuis
depuis qu'ils sont apparus ils ont avec
des yeux des ailes et des plumes oui
c'est vrai voyage et quelques dans une
époque mais c'est vrai que bon c'est un
détail
ils sont donc voilà les oiseaux c'est
aussi des espèces planctoniques du coup
parce que parce qu'ils n'ont pas évolué
depuis vos débuts 150 millions d'années
que j'existe c'est toujours des autres
voilà donc le piaggio là les humains
aussi c'est des espèces pour chroniques
tout est une espèce manque chronique
donc maintenant qu'on a bien pointé du
doigt le problème à savoir que le cliché
ces fossiles vivants le contre clichés
ces espèces pont chronique mais l'espèce
pont chronique du coup eh bien c'est la
même chose c'est la même définition
c'est exactement la même dépression donc
on fait qu'utiliser un autre mot pour
dire fossiles vivants et on est tous
pertinemment au courant que il faut pas
dire aussi le vivant voilà donc c'est
juste on utilise internet politiquement
correct voilà dix espèces pro chronique
enfin du politiquement correct inscrire
voilà c'est ça c'est drôle
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en
réalité bas il faut complètement abroger
le l'utilisation des sports chronique ou
alors il faut préciser la définition
c'est à dire que si vous voulez dire que
le coelacanthe appartient à une famille
qui existe depuis très longtemps qui a
conservé son plan d'organisation
générale
dîtes ça m'était en mots ce que vous
entendez par fossiles vivants mettez en
mots ce que vous entendez par espèce
pour chronique il peut faire avec pc
généralement ça ne fonctionne pas
généralement la notion qui se cache
derrière elle est systématiquement
fausse les façons toutes les espèces
évoluent alors c'est pas forcément
visible physiquement mais ça va quand
même évolué il n'y a pas d'espèces qui
n'évolue pas exactement donc déjà le
terme d' espèce pan chronique ou de
fossiles vivants sous son sens le plus
généralement admis qu'ils aient espèces
n'ayant pas tellement changé depuis un
certain nombre de millions d'années
c'est toujours quelque chose de
fallacieux qui se cache derrière ça
toujours ça ne veut ni à aucune espèce
qui répondent à cette définition
absolument aucune et la plupart des
fossiles vivants admis que ce soit les
crocodiles les lits mules et a reculé
tortues les varans de komodo et tout ça
ce sont des espèces éminemment moderne
qui ont beaucoup évolué et on le sait
grâce à leur adn et on le sait notamment
grâce à leurs fossiles donc fossile
vivant non espèces pont chronique non
plus non plus voilà on vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo où l'on testé
la nouvelle go pro et on vous dis à très
bientôt sur votre chaise ce lien